j'ai entre guillemets de la chance dans
cette malchance c'est que ayant des
antécédents familiaux puisque ma maman
ma grand mère sont mortes à ces jeunes
là cancer du sein et bien j'étais suivi
très régulièrement et donc c'est à
l'occasion d'un contrôle régulier et
bien qu'une petite tumeur a été détectée
une tumeur maligne c'est la sidération
c'est un peu le ciel qui vous tombe sur
la tête
en show avec l'équipe médicale j'ai opté
pour pour une opération et je peux
concevoir que certaines femmes ne
prennent pas cette option mais en tout
cas c'est cette opération est bien
permet d'éradiquer rapidement la tumeur
comment on fait pour se sentir femme
après une chirurgie le concernant la
poitrine maintenant on arrive voilà à
faire des choses qui permettent aux
femmes est de garder leur féminité
j'ai été beaucoup accompagné par ma
famille c'est important
par mes enfants par mon conjoint et par
le personnel médical est donc ça aide
ça aide à prendre ces décisions vous
avez choisi une forme de transparence en
disant que vous souffriez d'un cancer
pourquoi ce choix
écoutez c'est jamais facile d'en parler
son touche à l'intimé et puis c'est vrai
que je me suis aperçu que beaucoup de
femmes se sont confiés m'ont dit merci
et aussi apporter leur témoignage ça m'a
beaucoup aidé voilà de lire ce que des
femmes connues ou moins connues ont pu
traverser et donc je me suis dit si mal
mon expérience en tant que première
adjointe en tant qu'élu bas peut aussi
aider d'autres femmes
et bien c'est c'est important donc c'est
aussi pour ça que je les fais c'est une
maladie comme les autres qui se soigne
qui se guérit quand elle est détectée à
temps donc il faut ne pas avoir peur
d'aller faire des contrôles réguliers
des examens médicaux